Okay.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
[Silence]
in
the fifth chapter, the chapter of
vigilance of Allah's observation
authored
Continuing in the 62nd narration, the
narration of Abdullahb Abbass.
Iban Abbass's first name is
Abdullah.
And
Iban Abbass was born which year?
Which year?
[Arabic recitation]
after prophethood right after
prophethood. So
anywhere from 3 to 5 years before hijah
and what is his kuna
after his father after his father's name
and which year did he pass away
58 after hij
Very good.
So the narration of Abbas which is
collected by and others
and whichb
says
I was riding behind the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam one day and he said,
"Young boy, I'm going to teach you
a few words of belief, a few
statements to live by. Kat, I'm going to
teach you some statements, some words of
advice to live by." Notice how each one
of these
in the coming narration, it's a
collection of
it's a collection of
of
what could we say? It's a collection
of sayings that a person can live his
life by. They are very easy to remember.
They're very short sentences.
We all grew up with these things. Like
for instance, if I were to say right now
better safe than
sorry. See, we all we all know that
that's that is that is a saying that
people say a statement of wisdom,
right? A statement. We don't know who
said it originally. It's just a
statement that is of common sense. And
most times when a person is faced with a
decision or faced with a situation these
kinds of things come into their mind
whatever they grew up with. The prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam teaches Abbas
here exactly these kinds of statements.
Now he says to him
means that he's
prepubescent.
So he's at most here in this narration
10 11 years old very young he's teaching
him little statements right that are
easy for him to memorize but will stick
in his mind and when he is at a
crossroads in his life he will always
defer back to these types of narrations.
and so he says to him
the first statement,
preserve Allah's boundaries
and Allah will preserve you.
Preserve Allah's boundaries. Allah will
preserve
you.
preserve Allah's boundaries and
commandments and you will find him in
front of you. You'll find him ahead of
you whenever you need him. You'll find
him ahead of you in your life.
If you ask, ask from Allah. And what
this means is that even if you're asking
a human being for something,
right? You're going through the motions,
but really with your heart, you're
asking who? Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And this is merely an avenue of you
know knocking on all doors making sure
that you go through the motions
as they say. And so
even if you are receiving help or asking
for help from a human being and
something that a human being can do, you
are with your heart asking Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala first and foremost
before asking anyone else.
And if you seek
aid, seek aid in Allah.
And know that if all of the world,
all of humanity were to collaborate to
attempt to benefit you with something,
they could only benefit you with that
which Allah has already written for you.
And if they were to conversely
collaborate
to attempt to harm you with something,
they could only harm you with that which
Allah has already written upon you.
the pens of decree have already been
lifted off the page and the pages have
already dried. That ink is dried.
So we don't know that something is from
Allah's decree. That Allah has decreed
for something to happen
unless
what?
Unless it happens. The only way we know
something is part of Allah's decree is
once it's already gone, once it's
already happened. Either Allah or his
messenger inform us this is something
Allah has decreed.
So in that sense, it's a prophecy or
it's already happened before something
happens. Yes, we try to
work for the best and most desirable
outcome.
However, once we reach a point where
something has already happened, that's
it. This is part of Allah's decree. We
know for a fact that this is part of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's decree. And
that's why we are taught to say
this is Allah's decree and what he has
willed, he has done. Subhanahu
wa'ta'ala. That's how we look at the
past. When we look at the past, we look
at it that. If there's a lesson to
be learned,
good deed that was squandered, a sin
that was that was committed. We look
back with a face to learn from that
past. We look back with regret over our
misdeeds. However, with respect to if I
had done such and such, such and such
would have happened. This is ridiculous
because Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
decreed for that to happen. We know for
a fact that this has been decreed by
Allah. Why? Because it happened.
Therefore, if only I, who are you? Who
am I? Who what human being is going to
reach up into the heavens and change
Allah's decree? Where where is this
person? Right? If only I had done
imagine the hubris in such a statement.
Imagine the arrogance. If I had done
such and such, then the world would have
bent to my will. No, it wouldn't have.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala teaches us
this lesson and he tells us that
this kind of
wording
and the belief that accompanies it is
from comes from the heart and comes from
the belief system of the disbeliever.
The one who has not been taught by Allah
and his messengers.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says that the
disbelievers they look at their fallen
comrades
and say
if they had stayed with us they would
not have died. They would not have been
killed. I told him not to go. If he
listened to me he'd still be alive. So
all we have to do in order to stay alive
is listen to you. Amazing. So that means
that this person isn't going to die
either because he knows exactly what to
do to stay alive. The prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam was
instructed by Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
to say
if I knew the unseen
then I would accumulate much good for
myself and no harm would afflict me
because I'd avoid it because I'm a human
being and naturally I'm not going to let
something bad happen to me if I know
it's going to happen But good things
pass by, bad things happen. Why? Because
I don't know the future. I'm a human
being just you. That is something
that is the sole domain of Allah which
is knowledge of the future.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then teaches
us the proper belief with respect to
decree.
He says subhanahu wa ta'ala that
the
once the battle of took place and there
were many casualties shared by both
sides. Muslim had casualties,
the disbelievers had casualties. The
Muslim had a lot of casualties. Does
anyone know how many casualties
the Muslims suffered on the battle of
Wud? In the battle of Wud,
second major battle of Islam.
Does let me ask this. Does anyone know
how many prisoners of war were taken on
the day of
[Arabic recitation]
those prisoners of war before they had
permission explicit permission from
Allah.
So the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam then said
we have been given a choice by Allah.
Either we execute these prisoners
or we keep them as prisoners of war,
give them for ransom, but we will have
to suffer equal amounts in casualties in
our future campaigns.
The companions chose the second. The
second campaign was what? The second
major battle was how many casualties?
70.
So
many casualties. The disbelievers
had many casualties. However, Allah
teaches us the difference between the
view of the believer and the disbeliever
in viewing those same casualties.
The believers are taught
to say
The disbelievers,
they looked at those casualties and they
said
[Silence]
he says subhanahua
that they look at those casualties and
they say
if we had anything to say about it, if
it were up to us,
we would not be we would not fall here
to the sword in this place. Allah says,
"Say to them
that if it is written
that any of you meet his death
and he is safe in his home, tucked into
his bed,
he's safe at home.
The moment he has been written to
fall or die at a particular time or
place, he will come out of his home.
come out of that safety straight to his
straight to his death and the place
where he was written to die.
That is how the decree of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala works. Now
some of these things Iban Abbass maybe
doesn't understand yet. Not fully. He's
just a kid, right? Eight years old, 9
years old, 10 years old. Very
intelligent young young man. But
nonetheless a young man.
However, because the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam is teaching him
these short statements
that stick these things. He will learn
them. He will make his decisions based
on these statements and in the future he
will start to learn the wisdom behind
these statements. And this is what is
intended when we speak about teaching
our children.
It's not necessarily sitting down and
opening a book and having them memorize
things. That's good. That's great.
There's nothing wrong with that. But
these kinds of everyday incorporating
teaching the children small things like
that these are the kinds of things that
stick in a child's mind and in the
future they will continue to hold to and
a child's mind is a sponge. The
scholars say
they say memorization or learning
something as a child
is carving something in stone.
Once it's there, it's there,
right? How many of us
specifically memor memorize every little
detail of our childhood?
Not many things. However, things like
this I remember my father once said to
me. Remember my mother once said, I
remember this happened. I remember that
happened. The lessons, the things that
that you know that direct action
consequence, right?
That is learned and never forgotten even
if the circumstances behind it are
forgotten.
And this is what helps a person in his
life. One of the scholars, one of the
great scholars of hadith in Islam
was taken by the enemies
of Islam
and he was a contemporary of Imam Ahmed
or excuse me he was a contemporary of
so in the fifth year after
he was captured
and he was skinned alive.
And while he was being skinned,
they could hear him re repeating.
What is that statement? It's a statement
in
which Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
"All of that has been written in the
preserved tablet." They heard him
repeating this over and over.
This is something that had been written.
Ysefam,
could you imagine? And we'll end with
this. Could you imagine being in prison
for something you didn't do? Innocent
and then helping someone in prison.
They came to you. They asked for you to
interpret a dream. You interpret the
dream that look, you're going to get out
of here. And not only are you going to
get out of here, but you're going to be
part, you're going to be a courtiier of
the king himself. You're going to be the
guy that prepares his wine, which is a
very close level of very close kind
of servant, right? Because he's trusted
with the king's food. And so, you're
going to be the one preparing his his
wine for him. When you get there,
please mention me to him. Tell him that
I'm here. There was this man that you
knew in in prison. Look into his case
because he's innocent. Yes, I got you.
All right. I'll never forget you. What
are the things he probably said to you?
, same things we all heard before.
I'll never forget you. I I got you soon
as I get there. And then what happened?
completely forgot for years. Didn't just
forget a little bit. The scholars tell
us that he past that moment spent at
least seven more years in prison. Seven
years of his life
cuz someone what? Just forgot.
Sorry, it slipped my mind. How could
that slip your mind? You were in prison
with me. How could you forget something
that? And then not only did he
forget a little bit he clean forgot
who Ysef was
because Allah tells us that when the
king told his courtiers he said I had a
dream I'm looking for someone to
interpret it. Allah says
that he had to really sit and rack his
brain. How can do I know anyone that can
interpret dreams?
Oh yeah, that guy in prison, right?
Almost 10 years ago,
Ysef.
And so
Ysef's in prison all this time. Who
shows up? But the guy, the same guy,
what does he have here? He came to say,
"Hey, I got to the king. Don't worry.
I'm here for you. We didn't forget about
you. I'm looking into your case. The
king's mentioning. No,
you know what? You were right when you
told me before. I have another dream for
you to interpret. Really? You had
another dream for me to interpret. How
convenient,
right? But that's human nature. You
notice Yousef didn't say, "Oh, you have
a dream for me to interpret. You ready
to remember me now? He didn't say that.
He didn't even mention it. He came and
Ysef played the part Allah prepared him
for,
right? He didn't say, "Where have you
been? Why did you forget me? What
happened? I asked something small." He
didn't even remind him a second time.
He didn't even say
remind him again.
And he came. He said the dream. He
interpreted it again,
right?
Why? What could make a man this patient?
What could make a man this forgiving?
Belief in Allah's decree. Belief that
he's not dealing with the human being
right now. He's dealing with Allah. If
the whole world were to collaborate to
benefit me with something that Allah
hasn't written for me yet, it's not
[Arabic recitation]